What's going on guys, Mr. Zink here. If
you've been around me on social media at
all, you know that I am a huge fan of
Lucid Trading.
In today's video, we're going to break
down Lucid's plans, their policies to
get a payout, and how you can go about
copy trading on those accounts.
Let's get right into it.
Jumping right into it, the first thing
we're going to be taking a look at is
going to be Lucid's plans.
My personal favorites are going to be
the pros, more specifically the 25K Pro.
If you're a beginner trader or new on
your trading journey, the 25K Flex, 50K
Flex, those ones are going to be the
better options for you because there's
no consistency in the funded account. Or
if you want to skip the evaluation phase
altogether, you can go and get direct
accounts. These ones are a little bit
stricter on the rules, a little bit
about three times as expensive as well.
Going back over to the pros, these are
going to be the ones that we review
heavily in this video cuz as I said,
they are my favorite.
The 25K Pro, 50K Pro, 100K Pro, 150K
Pro.
These are one day to pass.
You can see the profit target on all
these, 1250 for the 25K, 3,000 for the
50K, 6,000, so on.
The reason I like the 25K so much is
because making 1250, even if it's in a
day, two days,
over the course of two months, it's
decently easy with one micro, two
micros.
3,000, 6,000, the profit targets on
these accounts a little bit harder to
get, especially if
you're trading micros like myself.
The biggest benefit to these accounts is
that when you do pass them, you go over
to your Lucid funded,
you can activate these immediately. Uh
my accounts are currently paused because
I'm being transitioned live with Lucid.
We'll talk about that a little bit
later.
But when you pass the accounts, let's
say you take a phenomenal trade 9:30 to
10:00 New York open,
you will fund that account by 10:05 that
same day.
Going over to the details on these
accounts, I passed them on Tuesday,
March 3rd,
and then I also traded on the funded on
Tuesday, March 3rd.
Phenomenal price action on that day.
We had a huge continuation to the
upside. I think it was about a 12 $12
move on Qs or almost 600 points on MNQ.
So I made a significant amount of profit
the same day that I passed the
evaluation.
And then these ones are also three days
to payout.
So it's 40% consistency.
If we go over to the account summary, go
back into the details,
40% consistency.
That is based on your max profit day.
When you do have your profit, it shows
what you need to make in order to reach
that consistency. So if I make a
thousand dollars, this will show me that
I need to make $1,400 to reach that
consistency target. Earn an additional
1,040.
Uh 400, sorry.
Your profit, this just tracks your total
profit. Uh again, I'm being transitioned
live, so all this stuff is negative
right now or just net neutral.
But my total profit is 1,137
on this account.
And then when you reach your buffer, so
the account is a 25K Pro,
it trails up a hundred dollars. That's
just for risk on Lucid's side. So once
you get a thousand dollars over that
25,100,
then you're qualified for a payout. You
need to make an additional 250, and you
request up to a thousand for a max
payout on your first payout.
Your second payout and anything after
that is 1,500 for these accounts.
The same thing is scaled for
and we'll go into their help section
here. You can go into the Lucid Pros and
the Lucid Pro plans, Lucid Pro payouts.
Scroll down, it tells you what your
minimum profit goal is, and then you can
see what the buffer balance is required.
So
for the 25K's, you need to make 1,100.
For the 50K's, you need to make 2,100.
100K's, 3,100. 150's, 4,600.
And then you can see your max payouts
here.
I wouldn't really worry too much about
the payout caps. I think that's
something that people
complain about for no reason.
If you're trading five accounts and you
get a thousand dollar payout over five
accounts,
$5,000 for making
2,100 in profit over five accounts,
really good plan there.
Going back to the dashboard now.
Everything that you see on this page is
that's it for your requirements on
getting a payout.
There's no hidden rules, there's no MAE
violation, and there's no hidden
consistency, micro scalping, micro
scaling.
They have automated systems that detect
if you're breaking any of their rules
that are on the back end like copy
trading over multiple accounts.
You have five accounts that you can
trade on one account. That's it.
Your profit needs to be
about 2,100 to get a max payout. Your
consistency needs to be 40%. That's
pretty much it.
The next benefit, and we can go back
over to
these payout slides here,
is that when you get to your third day,
so I started the account on Tuesday,
March 3rd,
Thursday, March 5th, I took the payout.
And when you get sent your payouts,
their average payout speed is five
minutes.
Meaning from your request, which the
platform updates end of day, so it's
about 5:00 p.m. ET,
from your payout request to in your bank
account,
for me anyway, it's about five minutes.
The quickest one I've had is about 40
seconds.
Meaning that if I request $5,000
after the split, which is 4,500, it's
90/10,
I get $4,500 in my bank account that I
requested at 5:20,
I'll get it at 5:21 to 5:25, which is
insane.
And then
excuse me.
I went and requested another payout on
March 10th, and I requested a third
payout with the same accounts on March
13th. And then they sent me an email on
March 13th after market close, you're
being transitioned live, and that is the
current process that I'm in right now.
All these benefits
are are why I think Lucid's probably one
of the best firms in the space right
now.
And what else we'll cover is if you are
a season trader and you want to go with
the higher size accounts, these ones
compared to other prop firms,
the payout reward
in terms of your profit target and then
what you're spending on the account,
I forgot to mention as well, these are
all one-time payments. Every single
account on Lucid, if you notice, is a
one-time payment up the top.
One of the only firms in the space that
doesn't have monthly recurring. So if
you are a beginner trader, season
trader, advanced trader,
you don't have to worry about how long
it takes you to pass the evaluation.
There's no monthly recurring, so you can
pass the account 30 days, 60 days, 90
days if you wanted to.
There's no inactivation.
Uh sorry, there's no activation fee.
And then there's no inactivity rule. So
as long as you're taking a trade every
30 days, you're fine. I think MyFunded
Futures has a seven-day rule.
Um most other firms have 30 days as
well.
You could trade the account for a year
if you wanted to, and you're still only
paying that 9450 once.
Going back over to the payouts for these
Lucid Pros,
we also covered the Lucid Flex and the
Lucid Direct.
It's a 90/10 profit split, so you keep
90% of what you make. Uh your first
10,000 as well is 100% yours, I believe.
For the larger accounts, I know I only
covered the 25K, but for the larger
accounts, you can see
2,000 for a 50K, 2,500 for 100K, 3,000
for 150K.
So you're talking about a 10K payout,
12,500, or a 15K payout on your first
payout cycle for spending
less than 1,200 in total.
All while being a one-time payment.
Now, the question I get asked the most
with these accounts is how do you go
about copy trading them? What platform
do you use? Is the platform reliable?
What I go and do is always trade on
Tradeovate. I don't use TradeZ yet. They
do have TradeZ as a platform. That's
what they're working on, and they're
also partnering with Tradefy. So when
they're up and running, you can copy
trade five Lucid accounts and five
Tradefy accounts, all funded.
You go over to Tradeovate.
In the top right, it says application
settings. You click on that.
You go all the way over to the right on
the top bar where it says add-ons. You
scroll down to group trade.
Activate that.
If it says green and active next to it,
you're good. You're all set to go. This
is free with any prop firm purchase that
uses Tradeovate. This is not something
that you need to pay more for.
This is free with the accounts that you
purchase.
Now that that's active, you go into the
top of your screen where it says
account. You click that.
And you go into manage groups.
I already have one activated, but I'll
go ahead and delete this and recreate
one. Let's hope it works even though the
accounts are paused.
You can name it whatever you want. I
like to name mine the payout that I
intend on getting with the prop firm.
So create the group. Make sure that the
group name is active on the top of your
screen.
And then drag all the accounts that you
want to group over into the right. So it
says added accounts, quantity
should always be one.
And then as long as all the accounts you
want to copy trade are on the right-hand
right-hand side, go ahead and click
save.
Account group successfully saved. Okay.
Exit out of that. Now, go into that
account setting again.
Click the drop-down menu. Click
that your payout and make sure that one
of the accounts that is within that
group
is the one that is selected.
Now, the next most important factor of
this for copy trading is that your
entries, which is under
uh
this quantity button right here,
quantity drop-down.
Your entries need You cannot type in
one. They need to be a denominator of
how many accounts you're trading.
So, if you're copy trading two accounts,
every order needs to be either two,
four, six,
eight, 10, so on.
Every two that you put into the
quantity, if you're copy trading two
accounts, is going to trade one
contract. If I'm copy trading on five
accounts and I want to trade two micros,
I need to put in 10.
If I'm copy trading on 10 accounts and I
want to trade one micro, still put in
10.
If I want to trade up to, let's say, two
full minis,
I'll put in 100 and that will take
uh 20 contracts over those five
accounts.
You need to make sure that all the
contracts that you're taking, the
drop-down menu unfortunately only goes
to 25.
So, you can just type them in by hand.
You need to make sure that all the
trades you're taking
always are divisible by however many
uh
accounts you're copy trading over.
When copy trading on Tradevate, you
cannot have OTC or ATM orders on,
meaning that when one side of that order
hits, the other one will automatically
fill and cancel.
So, if I have, let's say, a sell 10
limit here,
oops, I'm I'm transitioning live. You
just have to work with me for it.
If I have a order set at 23255
and I have my stop set at 23231
and I have my tick profit set at 23284,
if I have an order come down and hit my
stop loss
and all five of my contracts get filled
out,
my take profit order will remain
active and will remain on the chart. So,
you need to make sure that you are
manually watching your trades when
you're copy trading on Tradevate.
I always just hit exit at market and
cancel and that will exit all your
positions, your take profit, your stop
loss, and the current open position if
you do have one.
Or, you can go into the top right where
it says equity open P&L,
exit all positions and cancel all and
you can see no working orders or open
positions found and it will list all the
accounts that are copy traded.
They uh that along with the exit at
market and cancel is what I do every
every session that I'm done trading.
I spam this button about five times. You
can hear my mouse clicking. And then I
go into the top right, usually click
this twice just for my own personal
well-being.
Make sure that everything is
as it should be. I have no working
orders and then you can go ahead and
close out of that position.
Or close out of that tab.
That's how you go about copy trading. If
you want to rewatch that, I will put a
timestamp on the video so you can just
skip back and watch the copy trading
segment.
Uh
that's about it for Lucid.
Now,
I I've
vaguely mentioned the speed of the
payouts. I really want to emphasize
this. This is by far the fastest payout
speed I've ever had on any prop firm
I've ever traded with.
They're instant activation
and instant approval on the payouts.
So, when you activate your evaluation
account, it's instant.
You can trade on your funded account the
same day that you pass the evaluation
and when you take a payout,
it is
within your bank account, if you're a US
citizen anyway, it's within your bank
account within 5 minutes.
If you're not a US citizen,
they have you go through, I think it's
Worksite or uh
Workmore,
something like that. It's usually within
your bank account within 2 days.
So, definitely some of the fastest
speeds in terms of payouts, instant
approval,
instant activation on the evaluation
accounts,
and a very clean dashboard.
Even if you don't have uh Tradevate or
TradeC active, you can just click on the
top right under your accounts, launch
TradeC, launch Tradevate.
I haven't used TradeC yet. I don't have
an account set up with them. They are
still somewhat beta, I believe,
meaning that they they do have some
slippage, they have some errors.
I would trust that as long as the firm
does, so you're free to use that. I just
prefer Tradevate. It's my own
preference.
And then you have your credentials up
here in the top right as well. I'm not
going to show that for obvious reasons.
And then you can see
you can also go and find where all your
accounts are if you want to trade on a
couple funded accounts, a couple direct
accounts. You can have up to 10 accounts
active on Lucid. You can only have five
accounts active at any given time.
Uh five funded accounts, sorry. So, five
direct, five funded.
If you have five funded, you can also
have five evals at the same time as
well.
And then you can go over to your
certificates and you can see all your
payout rewards, your your passes
filtered out for
the month, the year.
This is all in one location as well.
Uh they have leaderboards on here if you
do want to push for that.
And then everything else you can find
pretty much as easy you want on the
platform. I really like their platform.
It's very quick to go and get the
frequently asked questions as well.
Uh lastly, we're going to talk about the
live and live policies.
So, their new live structure, which is
what I'm being transitioned to right
now, this is what you should be shooting
for.
They're really easy to work with and
they're one of the few firms that also
doesn't ban you if you blow a live
account. So, after receiving up to
payout number five, they can move you to
live before payout number five.
You will have about a 5-to-10-day wait,
5-to-10 business day
wait before they transition you to live.
You will get up to five accounts or one
live account per funded account that you
had.
So, if I go back to my dashboard,
I had five 25K Pro funded.
All five of these accounts are going to
be moved live.
There's just a a waiting period. I
should have in this coming week.
When those accounts are moved live, I'm
on page
you will have essentially a fresh start
on the funded account. So, I'm trading
the 25K Pro. I'm going to start five new
funded accounts that are moved to live
with a $1,000 starting live drawdown.
Two minis to 20 micros is my limit. So,
it's essentially the same as trading on
the 25K Pros when I first funded them
uh funded them.
The reason I think everyone should be
shooting for this is when you get to the
live account, they give you and this is
only for the first time you move live.
We'll talk about subsequent live
removals uh or transitions to live.
When you get moved live your first time
after reaching a $1,000 profit, they add
another thousand per account.
So, I again will have five accounts.
It's essentially a 5K fun uh 5K live
account. I'll have five 25K live
accounts with a $1,000 starting balance.
Once I reach a $1,000 target or profit,
they will add another thousand into the
account.
So, their example on here is a trader
moved live with five 50K funded
accounts. Each account starts with $0
balance and $2,000 drawdown. The trader
earns $2,000 in each account. Lucid
releases a $2,000 live bonus to each
account. Each account now holds $4,000
total live capital across five accounts
up to 20,000.
So, when you reach your first thousand
dollar profit on a 25K or 2,000 or 50K,
3,000 100K and so on,
they
double what you have in the account.
All the way up to 150K. So, you make
half the profit, they add another half
in.
If I want to take a
10K payout,
I only need to make a $1,000 profit.
Now, the best part about Lucid in terms
of their live transition
is that when you blow your live account,
which I'm sure some people will, uh AJ
actually came out and said 95% of
traders that get moved live with Lucid
blew their accounts.
So, only 5% of the people that get moved
live are still trading live with them.
You only go on a cool down period for 4
weeks.
So, even if you blow your account,
you you're down the dumps, you're sad
that you're you think you're going to
lose your access to Lucid, you're only
on cool down for 4 weeks and you can
start the whole process again.
The only issue is that when you get
moved live for the second time, third
time, fourth time, how many however many
times you want,
you will not have that live bonus
active. This is only for
people that get moved to live for their
first time.
If you want to take a payout from your
accounts as opposed to getting moved
live, you can.
I I'm not sure where that is on this
page. Let's see if I can find it.
I can't I could show you the email as
well. I'll bring that up here here a
minute.
When you get moved
they give you an option of taking 80% of
what you have on your live balance. So,
if I go back to my accounts here, as you
can see, I had about a $1,000 balance
per account.
I was given the option to take 80% of
the $5,000 that I had in the buffer.
If you guys trade more aggressively than
I do, or if you save more on each
account than I do,
let's say each one of these accounts had
10,000 for a balance on it. So, I had
$50,000 in funded accounts
or funded SIM profit.
They give you the option to take 80% of
that, and then still go on the 4-week
cool down, and after that 4 weeks, you
can come back and trade with them.
So, if you traded up to 50,000 in
profit, they say, "Hey, we want to
transition you to live. You can take
$40,000, which will get be paid out
within two business days,
and then you go on a 4-week cool down,
and then you can start trading with
Lucid again.
They said this because AJ mentioned and
I actually can go and pull up his tweet
here real quick.
Just a minute.
Uh AJ trading Lucid.
So, his tweet, if I can find it.
Just a minute here.
Talking about
moving live. There we go.
So, all the stats on this tweet, he
said, "95% of traders that went live
blew up."
Uh at the bottom, you can see that it
says, "After giving traders two choices,
here's what we learned. Most traders who
cashed out were better off with the
money in their bank. The ones that blew
their live accounts didn't wish they had
a bigger balance.
Regard- Regardless of what option they
took, they all wanted another chance at
SIM."
Based on those stats and all the other
data we've collected, the Lucid team has
come to a clear conclusion. A similar
prop firm like Lucid is never the final
step in a trader's journey.
Our focus moving forward is building a
model where traders can move to SIM to
live and back again as many times as
they need.
So, as long as you're not falling within
the parameter of people that have
reckless YOLO behavior,
which is what they say right here,
"Traders who repeatedly blow live
accounts due due to reckless or YOLO
behavior may be subject to longer cool
downs."
As long as you're not within that group,
you have nothing to worry about. You can
go
funded to live,
cool off for 4 weeks, fund to the live,
cool off for 4 weeks
as many times as you want.
These are all my reviews on Lucid. If
you guys do want to participate in these
accounts or show me some support,
code Zink, which I will put in the
description.
Probably one of the best prop firms in
the space right now. They're personally
my ranked
number one.
I think they're at the top of the prop
firm game right now.
Best of the best in terms of
authenticity,
payout speed, rules, and their support
usually answers within an hour.
That will do it for today's video. Thank
you guys for hopping along, tagging
along.
Hope you enjoyed the video. I'll be back
for another review on either My Funded
Futures or Trade the Five later this
week. See you later.